(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brain,
long the master of fire,
tools and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(upbeat music)
- Thank you Tim and thank you to CARTA
for their vision in sponsoring
these wonderful symposia.
I want to start with one picture here
which is a picture of what was intended
to inculcate into the
readers of this magazine,
Time magazine, that DNA did everything
that you would want in a car.
(audience titters)
And unfortunately for this ad, of course,
Volvo was taken over by Ford.
So there's been a cultural
change since this ad came out.
We don't know yet what the cultural change
actually will bring about.
It hasn't been long enough.
But the general problem that we face
is how important are the genes,
relative to the other things
that go on in the human life?
And what I'm going to do
is to start quite a bit of time ago
with a picture that tells you about
what my colleague, Cavalli-Sforza,
who just died four weeks' ago,
and I called the serial founder effect
of people leaving Africa
between 50 and 100 thousand years ago.
And what you see here
are the people who are the most variable.
They have the most variation
in terms of colors and genes
and when they leave Africa,
a small number of those individuals
approach this area here,
probably the Levant
and then they diverge into groups
that go to Africa and Asia.
Some go down into the Oceanic area
and the final group to move,
moves across this varying bridge here
into the Americas
and you can see the
pattern of variation here
is much less variable than here.
Now, some economists,
and I'm referring to
these particular ones,
think that there's something else going on
and they claim that the
pattern of human variation
has been associated with
economic development.
And they did it by doing
the following picture
which is this infamous
paper by Ashraf and Galor
where if you look at this graph here
which is essentially population
density in the year 1500
which the economists chose,
and this is a pattern of
lack of genetic variation.
So the people who lack most
of the absent variation,
or the people who are the most variable
are the Africans and the people
who are the least variable
are the indigenous Americans.
And they concluded that
having an intermediate
amount of variation was conducive
to economic development,
and this is just one,
population density was just
one of the silly things
that they did.
But the idea behind bringing
this to your attention
is that this is published
in the most eminent
economic journal in America,
in the world in fact
and not only is it silly, but it's wrong.
They claimed that a one
percentage point decrease
in diversity for the most diverse society
would be associated with a rise
in its population density by 64%.
So this kind of misuse of numbers
not only was it in that paper
but it also was brought
over into another paper
they wrote about cultural fragmentation.
And it's the trying to point
out the genetic diversity
actually is a cause of
these social phenomena.
Not only were they silly,
but they were wrong
and there were a series
of papers published
shortly after this one came out
that addressed that their
population estimates were wrong,
their time of getting
agriculture was wrong,
whether there was
cooperation in the societies
they were looking at was wrong,
and of course, how much
genetic diversity was related
to innovation was wrong too,
because fruit flies have
a lot more genetic diversity than humans.
Their innovation is not nearly
as great, as far as we know.
(audience laughs)
So in the human genome
diversity cell line panel,
which Luca Cavalli-Sforza and I
started to develop in the early 1990s.
We looked at genomic variation
in people from around the
world, 52 populations,
and where they're located is
marked with these red Xs here
and those peoples we would
love to have a lot more
in the human genome diversity cell line.
And people now have in their laboratories
hundreds of populations
from around the world
where the DNA is currently
available for analysis.
Our idea was to have this
panel available in Paris
and any lab in the world
could just get the DNAs
and do their studies.
And this was the first study
that we did on those people
in that study.
These are indigenous Americans,
these are indigenous Africans
and these are Europeans
but the interesting thing about this slide
is how many of these
populations around the world
have ancestry in more than one place
including these people who
have ancestry in three places
and the Uyghurs in China
and Hazara in Pakistan and Afghanistan
have ancestry in three
different continents.
So, ancestry is a much better idea
about describing populations than is race.
Now, if we go back to
that silly economic slide,
when you look at the
data that we've produced
from that study, they were using my data,
that's what made me so mad.
(audience laughs)
And these were the data they were using.
We plotted mean diversity
as a function of distance
from Addis Ababa and what you can see here
is that the Africans have
the highest diversity
and the indigenous Americans
have the lowest diversity
and we can ask why.
Well I showed you why
in that migration trait.
It was a property of
prehistorical migrations
that the African population
was the population
from which everybody else was derived.
They have the most variation,
they've been there the longest,
accumulated the most mutations
and the indigenous Americans
have been in their small group
that came across from the varying bridge.
That group's only been there
in position for 15,000 years
as opposed to the 100,000 years
before the indigenous Africans left.
Now to prove that, we looked at the DNA
of these peoples around the world
to find out how long the stretches of DNA,
without any variation, should be there.
And what we see is that there
are two kinds of reasons
why people lack variation.
One is the historical phenomenon
that I told you about,
of small population size,
that these are the
indigenous American people.
And the other one is a cultural phenomenon
and these are all the Islamic
populations in our study
and they have the same
level of homozygosity,
lack of variation, as
the indigenous Americans
and the reason is,
these populations practice
first cousin marriages.
These are highly inbred
populations from Pakistan,
Afghanistan and the Middle East.
So the cultural explanation is
the explanation for this part
and the historical explanation
is the explanation for that part.
That's the demography side.
Now, since that study,
there's been a 189 populations studied
and I'd ask you to focus on this list.
What we see here are
the indigenous Americans
and what we're looking at
here is having 5 million
nucleotides without any variation
and you will see mostly
that the populations
in the Americas have a very
high rate of homozygosity.
The populations of Islamic extraction
have a very high rate of homozygosity
and these populations here
are really interesting,
these are the Jewish populations.
And one of those populations,
particularly interesting,
this one here, that's
a population in Israel
called the Samaritans.
And most of you have
heard of the Samaritans
'cause there was a good one.
(audience laughs)
Now, the Samaritans are
an interesting group
because they don't believe
that they should be separated
from the other Israelites.
They have a very interesting history.
This is the high priest of the Samaritans.
Currently there are about 850 of them,
half live in the center of Tel Aviv
and half live in a
village in the West Bank.
But in 1917 there were
150 Samaritans left.
They spoke Aramaic and
they did not believe
in any of the Bible, except
the five books of Moses.
The rest of it, the
prophets and the writings,
they didn't care about.
And part of the reason is their history.
This is the Assyrian Empire
between 900 and 607 BC
And this is the history.
Everybody can read this for themselves.
(audience laughs)
This is called the Nimrud Prism
in which Emperor Sargon II,
who conquered the
Northern Kingdom of Israel
in the year 722 BC,
wrote down what he did.
And this is the story.
Now if you want an easier bit,
you can read the translation here
that he tells that he took out the people
as was his custom, from
the Northern Kingdom,
moved them to what is now Iraq
and replaced them with people
who he already had conquered.
And this was his pattern.
However the Samaritans
believe that they descend
from people who never left,
that they are the
descendants of the children
of Manasseh and Ephraim, two
of the children of Joseph,
two sons of Joseph, and they never left.
Now the Bible actually has a contradiction
about these people because
if you look at the big
Book of Kings, it says exactly
what the Nimrud Prism says,
that the king of Assyria
brought men from Babylon
and these other places
and placed them in the cities of Samaria
instead of the children of Israel.
Unfortunately, the Chronicles
says exactly something else
because Hezekiah is the
king of the Solomonic Empire
and this is in the year 700,
this is after the conquest.
So if the Israelites had
been taken over and left
and there were none there,
why would he would be
writing to Israel and Judah
and the children of Ephraim and Menassah
and asking them to come to
Jerusalem to keep The Passover?
So there's a contradiction there.
And the scholars say,
oh Chronicles is written
a lot longer after,
it goes to about 400 BC
and the Book of Kings
is really kosher, we've
gotta believe that one,
so either way, there's
something to explain here
and so we tried to explain it.
Being a Samaritan is passed
down along the male line.
Male Samaritans can marry anybody,
and the children is a Samaritan.
There are only four families.
Cohen, Joshua-Marhiv,
Danfi and Tsedaka and they are endogamous,
they marry within the line.
So it's not unexpected
that they have the highest
inbreeding coefficient
of any population in the world.
They're the only population that I know of
where a 1/4 of the mothers and sisters
of colorblind men are also colorblind.
Because as you know,
colorblindness is usually in males.
So the Samaritans are
really quite interesting
but as a consequence of
this cultural phenomenon
of preferring to marry within the line,
within the marriage line, they
have these genetic properties
which we can get at by
looking at the Y chromosome
because the descending gene
which defines you as a Samaritan
is your Y chromosome,
because only males can pass
being a Samaritan down.
So we did that,
we looked at the Y
chromosomes of the Samaritans
and compared them to all
the other populations
of Jewish people in Israel
and in addition to Palestinian
and to Ethiopian Jews
and to Druze and Bedouins
and low and behold,
they're the closest by
far to today's Cohens
and Cohens are the high
priests of the Jewish religion.
So it turns out that
Samaritans are actually related
closer to the Jewish people
and they're Israelites.
They must be Israelites to
have this close relationship
on the Y chromosome.
If you study mitochondrial DNA,
it's a totally different
story because the women
are coming from everywhere,
they're not from Samaritans.
So you won't see anything
like this, which we did.
Which is an interesting phenomenon.
So the culture has again
defined the pattern
of genomic variation.
Why did this happen?
Well, this guy, Josephus,
an interesting fellow
who was hated by the
Jews at the time because
he was a turncoat.
He joined the Romans and became a writer
and reporter for the Romans.
And the Romans who were in
Israel and destroying the temple,
and particularly attached
himself to Vespasian
who destroyed the temple in the year 70.
And he writes about a time of history,
300 or 400 years before him
and he mentions Sanballetes
who is that Persian governor
of Samarian Judea and
Manasses who was the brother
of the high priest in Jerusalem.
Now he'd have to be a Cohen
because only Cohens were high priests.
And Josephus says that
Sanballetes gave Manasses
his daughter and along with
other of the high priests,
they converted to become
essentially Jewish Samaritans.
So they were Cohens.
So the male lineage descends,
according to Josephus,
from that line.
So we don't know whether
there's any truth to this.
This is the only evidence that
I and my religious scholars
have been able to find
to say why the Samaritans
should be related to the Cohens,
the high priests of the Jewish religion.
Now my final example of
how culture affects genes
concerns the Canadian fur
trade and tuberculosis.
This is a pattern of the global
incidence of tuberculosis
rates from the United Nations documents.
It hasn't changed much since then.
Maybe gotten a little
worse down here in Africa,
southern Africa with the advent of HIV.
This is a story from the famous book
written by Ferguson in 1928
about how many deaths occurred from TB
in indigenous Canadian populations.
And these two peaks which
tell you over 10%, maybe 14%
of indigenous Americans in
Canada died in those times.
They died because they
were put into reservations
and the reservations were
extremely badly designed.
The people were dying like
flies, of infectious diseases.
They had no blankets, no ventilation.
So the question is, if these
people had that problem
then why is it the case that
so many indigenous Americans
in that part of Canada died?
This lady who's pictured here
in the canoe of the fur traders
going down this long river here,
this river zone here, from Quebec,
we found out that if we
actually looked at the DNA
of the bacterium that was in
the Canadian indigenous peoples
it was exactly the same DNA
that was in the people from Quebec.
Those people, the French Canadians,
were in the North West fur trading company
and the French had a different
culture from the British.
The French cohabited with
the indigenous people
and they passed on their TB bacteria.
The British never homesteaded,
they never passed on anything,
they were hands off the indigenous people.
So what we see is this
culture of cohabiting
with the indigenous people,
that the French Canadian fur trappers did,
was the reason why that bacterium
passed these 1,500 kilometers
into the indigenous people.
So in conclusion, it's obvious
that if you look at the cultural
context around these human behaviors
and the variation of the DNA,
you can see that you can't
say that it's the DNA
that's causing these variations.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)